bien connu l'engouement de bruxelles dès
qu'il s'agit de faire l'éloge de
personnalités qui se démarque sur la
scène internationale bach leur
opposition à des systèmes politiques
dont le et peu friande
ça fait partie du jeu géopolitique
entretenir des relations cordiales dans
la forme avec ses adversaires tout en
travaillant à leur discrédit quoi de
plus classique
l'union européenne se considérant comme
étant l'exemple à suivre en matière de
libertés individuelles et comme
championne des droits humains a décidé
cette année de décerner le prix sakharov
à ce qu'elle nomme opposition
démocratique en biélorussie emmené par
sa figure de proue souhaite la nati
canucks callas réfugiés en lituanie
c'est un honneur d'annoncer que les
femmes et les hommes de l'opposition
démocratique en biélorussie sont les
lauréats 2020 du prix sakharov
ils ont de leur côté une chose que la
force brutale ne pourra jamais vaincre
la vérité d'abandonner pas votre combat
nous sommes à vos côtés
la vérité voilà une belle et solennelle
déclaration qui salue un mouvement de
contestation populaire dans un pays
finalement très peu connu et médiatisé
en occident la biélorussie le pouvoir
d'alexandre loukachenko président depuis
1994 s'essouffle d'année en année la
contestation massive des élections de
l'été dernier a entraîné des
manifestations d'une ampleur sans
précédent
les biélorusses veulent du changement
des élections plus libre et plus
transparente
en revanche rien ne semble indiquer une
volonté de se rapprocher de bruxelles ou
d'intégrer l'union européenne mais mais
mais mais la biélorussie est aux portes
de son voisin et alliés éternels la
russie et dans un contexte géopolitique
complexe de quasi guerre froide entre
lui et les forces de l'otan et moscou le
pays constitue un véritable point clé
décerner des prix de la paix de l'amour
du courage de la liberté porte toujours
en soi un but et vidéos logis politique
d'ailleurs qui sont les précédents
lauréats du prix sakharov
en 2017 l'opposition démocratique
vénézuélienne en pleine crise nationale
et de manifestations contre la politique
de nicolas maduro que bruxelles et
accessoirement accessoirement washington
ne portent pas dans leur coeur en 2018
oleg cnsof cinéaste ukrainien fervent
activiste d'euros maidan militants des
droits de l'homme et accessoirement
accessoirement qui a été emprisonnés
pour terrorisme puis libéré en septembre
2019 lors de l' échange de prisonniers
entre la russie et l'ukraine
le prix sakharov se veut être le
spécialiste du soutien aux opposants et
de l'ingérence politique partout dans le
monde sauf en europe évidemment pourquoi
parce qu'en europe c'est bien connu la
contestation populaires violentes les
manifestations appelant à la démission
des dirigeants à la répression policière
et politique ça n'existe pas ben si non
d'où vient cet entrain soudain envers la
biélorussie le peuple biélorusse a bien
le droit de prétendre à décider de son
avenir encore heureux mais cet
empressement de l'occident a volé à son
secours alors que deux biélorusses ne
lui ont globalement rien demandé on
semble malheureusement n'être pas exempt
d'arrière-pensées war peut-être même de
stratégie expansionniste et s'il le se
préoccuper finalement moins de l'avenir
du peuple biélorusse que de la
possibilité d'étendre davantage sa zone
d'influencé dans la région vers l'est et
le proche voisinage russe
[Musique]